ينضم الينا من القاهره الممثله على مرسي
اهلا بك تسمعني
اهلا وسهلا اهلا ومرحبا يا مساء الورد
اهلا بك شكرا
رمضان كريم
في مصر بعد ظهورك بشخصيه عن فخري في مسلسل
الكبير اوي كيف شفت هالتفاعل وحب الجمهور
لك وكيف قدرت تجمع بين الشخصيه مرعبه
وشخصيه فكاهيه كوميديه في نفس الوقت
[موسيقى]
اولا
انا سعيد جدا ان انا معكم الاول وعلى
شاشتكم العظيمه العربيه لانه هي منصه
ونافذه عظيمه صادقه جميله انا من
متابعينها
اولا شخصيه عم فخري هي شخصيه موجوده في
واقعنا وداخل كل حد فينا هي شخصيه
فيها ابعاد كتير قد انت لما تشوفيها او
تتفرجي عليها يعني ممكن تصعب عليك او او
تشفقي عليها
ولكن انا خدت الجانب منها النفسي وحطيته
داخل نظراتي داخل حركاتي ولكن بيقول كلام
ممكن يؤدي للكوميدي للتخفيف لانه انا
مشكلتي مع مسلسل الكبير ان هو مسلسل ضاحك
وكوميدي ويقدم وبدا بداياته كانت للطفل
فاننا اقدم شخصيه احط فيها المعادله ما
بين الكوميدي وما بين الشخصيه
السايكوباتيه كان طبعا ده كان مهم جدا
وخلينا كمان نسالك يعني انت في البدايه
بتخطف مربوحه ليه وبتخض الكبير عليها كده
ليه
[موسيقى]
انا اتخطفت مربوحه
خطفت مربوحه على انه كان لازم اخطفها لمده
حلقتين تبقى معايا لان انا اولا من عشاقها
وبحب هذه الممثله رحمه احمد جدا
وحبيت اناغش واصارع مع الكبير شويه
ولكن انا خطفتها كبنتي
فانا سعيد جدا بالعمل والله مع احمد مكي
واحمد الجندي ورحمه احمد وكل طاقم العمل
لانه هو مسلسل جميل وناجح وانا طبعا انا
بشكر الاستاذ تامر مرسي السينرجي
واحمد الجندي واحمد مكي لانه هم اللي
فتحولي الفرصه الجميله دي وانا سعيد جدا
بشخصيتي عم فخري وعلى فكره انا بفكر ان
انا اعمل عشر حلقات شخصيه عم فخري
والحسناوات
واخدين بالكم
في جمله جمله مهمه لازم نستوقف عندها عمي
فخري والحسناوات
انت عاده ما تقدم ادوار قصيره لكنها مؤثره
السؤال اللي يحب الكل يعرفوا يعني كيف
تختار ادوار بتكون فيها ضيف شرف او ادوار
قصيره وكيف وما هي العوامل التي تجعلها
مؤثره في العمل الفني او الدرامي
اولا لابد ان نضيف الشرف يكون مؤثر
وجزء كبير جدا لا يتجزا من اعمده العمل
والسياق الدرامي يعني اذا اذا شلنا الدور
اختل السياق واختل اختلت اعمده العمل
الدراسي هنا انا بوافق فورا لو لو لقيته
انه هياثر لو اتشال انا بعمل الضيف شرفي
اما اذا
لم يؤثر
وشلناه والدرامه ماشي عادي هنا ده مش ضيف
شرف ده بنسميها مجامله فانا قمت على مدار
تاريخي كله في كتير جدا عملت الحاجتين
ولكن بفضل ربنا كان في الحاجتين كان ربنا
بيوفقني فيهم لان انا مؤمن انه انا بمثل
الدور وما ليش دعوه هو صغير قصير المشاهد
ااا انا انا انا بتعامل مع نفسي انا ممثل
جيد بقوم بدور ولابد ان انا اعمل فيه
نتيجه صادقه للناس سواء بقى بطوله مش
بطوله انا ما عنديش المقياس ده انا عندي
مقياس انه انا بستمتع فبالتالي متفرج
بيستمت الممثل صادق ومشاعره بتوصل للناس
هيك بتزيد نجوميته بصير بيكسب قلوب الناس
اكثر بس يا استاذ علاء احنا عم نشوفك كمان
انه قلت لنا وشفنا بكثير تصريحات انه
واجهت صعوبه في لزمات ويجز يعني اللي
ذكرتها اكثر من مره بمشاهدك في العمل انت
ليه واجهت صعوبه في تاديه حفظ الاغاني
وكيف تفاعل الناس معكم تؤدي
انا اولا من من احباب ويجز بحبه جدا وبحب
هذا الشاب ونجاحه ومؤمن ان هو مطرب مطرب
جيده مطرب جمهوره
وانا راجل شويه عجوز عنه شويه وعجوز عن
جيده ولكن انا من محبين التجديد محبي
طفرات الجديده
حبيبتي الله يحفظك فانا انا انا شويه لحفظ
الاغاني عندي في شخصيتي صعبه انا ممكن
بحفظ دور بسهوله بحفظ الكلام برتجل انما
الاغاني بالتحديد من تركتي انا صعب جدا
احفظ اغنيه فكانت دي مشكله عطلت التصوير
شويه على فكره وكنت انا بنسى الجمل ما
بعرفش اقول السجع بتاعها بشكل كويس وفي
نفس الوقت خايف اغلط فيها لان انا عارف ان
كتير جدا من الشباب والشابات جمهور ويجز
واحبابه وحافظينها
فاخدت مجهود فيها لدرجه انا انا دلوقتي مش
عارف ان هو غير
اللي فات ناشف واللي جاي كله طري يعني
هتيجي بس اللي انا حافظها
ههه
[موسيقى]